jeune reporter nadège abderrazak nadège
bonsoir le plan de les confinant qui a
donc été approuvé ce soir à l'assemblée
nationale
c'est sans surprise dans le clan de
déconfinement a été approuvée vous
l'avais dit à 368 voix pour cent contre
à l'issue de cinq heures de débats à
l'assemblée nationale alors lors de son
discours pendant une heure le premier
ministre a mis en garde le de
déconfinement aura lieu le 11 mais
seulement si les français respectent le
le confinement jusqu'à échéance et si le
nombre de contaminations n'augmente pas
un déconfinement qui ne sera pas le même
partout et pour tout le monde ait les
départements seront différenciées selon
leur situation sanitaire en fonction de
l'activité du virus département vers
déconfinement appliqué normalement dès
qu'on département rouge le déconfinement
prendra une forme plus strictes une
carte sera présenté chaque soir à partir
du 7 mai par le directeur général de la
santé le chef du gouvernement a de
nouveau rappelé aujourd'hui l'importance
du respect des gestes barrières de la
distanciation sociale au delà de la date
du 11 mai il a aussi appelé à maintenir
le télétravail autant que possible il a
invité les entreprises à protéger leurs
salariés au sujet du port des masques
qui il affirme il y en aura pour tout le
monde le port du masque et qui est
obligatoire qui sera obligatoire à
partir du 11 mai dans les transports en
commun depuis que nous sommes rassurés
sur notre capacité à servir les
soignants au sens large en masque
nous incitons l'ensemble des acteurs à
se procurer des masques et les données
des douanes le montre d'ailleurs assez
clairement il rentre bien plus de
masques dans le pays que le gouvernement
no comment et croyez-moi il en commande
puisque nous recevons près de 100
millions de masques chirurgicaux par
semaine désormais est que nous recevrons
près de 20 millions de masques grand
public lavable à compter du mois de mai
progressivement nous parviendrons
à une situation classique où les
français pourront sans risque de pénurie
se procurer des masques grand public
dans tous les commerces
en attendant il faut que l'état les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises
l'initiative privée soient
complémentaires et non concurrents
j'invite toutes les entreprises quand
leurs moyens le permettent a veillé à
équiper leurs salariés c'est une
condition elles le savent et le disent
de la reprise les régions et l'état
mettra en place un appui aux tpe et aux
travailleurs indépendants au delà des
initiatives déjà prises par un certain
nombre de branches ou d'organisations
professionnelles une plateforme de
e-commerce sera mise en place par la
poste à compter du 30 avril et
distribuera à ceux qui en ont besoin
chaque semaine plusieurs millions de
masques grand public les pharmacies et
la grande distribution seront invités à
vendre dans des conduits dans des
conditions que nous définirons avec eux
pour éviter les phénomènes de pénurie
des masques jetables ou là bas le
gouvernement s'est aussi donné
l'objectif de réaliser 700 mille tests
virologiques par semaine pour les
personnes symptomatique ou encore en
contact avec des personnes malades en
écoute nous sommes fixé l'objectif de
réaliser au moins 700 mille tests
virologiques par semaine 11 mai pourquoi
700 me parce que le conseil scientifique
nous dit à ce stade que les modèles
épidémiologiques prévoit entre 1000 et
3000 cas nouveaux chaque jour à partir
du 11 mai parce qu'à chaque cas nouveau
correspondra en moyenne le test d'au
moins 20 à 25 personnes l'ayant croisé
dans les jours précédents 3000 x 25 x 7
cela donne 525 milles test par semaine
sept cent mille nous donne la marge qui
nous permettra en plus des tests des
chaînes de contamination que je viens de
décrire de mettre en oeuvre des
campagnes de dépistage comme nous
l'avons déjà engagés pour les ehpad
notamment nous avons engagé la
mobilisation conjointe des laboratoires
publics et privés qui peuvent
aujourd'hui montée en charge très
rapidement en termes de capacité cette
mobilisation permettra de garantir
surtout
territoire un accès de proximité aux
prélèvements nous allons enfin faire
passer à 100% la prise en charge de
cette de ces tests pardon par
l'assurance maladie et il faudra
attendre encore un petit peu pour un
retour à la vie normale les commerces
pourront réouvrir le 11 mai excepté les
cafés et les restaurants réouverture
également des bibliothèques des petits
musées mais pas des plus grands spas des
cinémas pas à des théâtres les plages
seront inaccessibles au moins jusqu'au
1er juin les grandes manifestations
sportives et culturelles en de plus de
5000 personnes ne pourront pas se tenir
avant le mois de septembre les lieux de
culte pourront en revanche réouvrir à
partir du 11 mai sans grande cérémonie
avant le 2 juin voilà ce qu'on pouvait
retenir de ce plan de déconfinement
présenté cet après-midi par edouard
philippe est donc adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale merci neige à deraa